[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Frédéric Lamandé
programmateur artistique au Saxe à
Achères bonjour bonjour je suis alors le
sac c'est donc une salle de spectacle
située à Achères vous proposez des
spectacles et concerts tout au long de
l'année quels sont vos ambitions en
termes de programmation culturelle sur
le territoire d'achat alors nos
ambitions emballent sont multiples
notamment de trouver des pépites et de
les proposer à notre public
d'être aussi dans la diversité c'est à
dire proposer aussi bien de la chanson
que du rock que de la soul music et
toucher un maximum de monde et puis
aussi
notre programmation et et
enfin je voulais dire on a une grosse
programmation qui est tournée vers le
jeune public que ce soit en famille sur
le temps scolaire et
et au centre de loisirs en gros nos
ambitions c'est de faire connaître la
musique et le spectacle vivant au plus
grand nombre donc une programmation
finalement très éclectique pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut proposer justement une
programmation éclectique aux ylinois
alors c'est un petit peu notre choix
c'est à dire que on est aussi dans un
bassin de de
vie par exemple à côté de chez nous il y
a la clé dans notre bassin ils sont du
Val d'Oise mais il y a Vauréal il y a le
12 à cerg donc c'est c'est l'idée de se
compléter aussi de pas proposer
forcément la même chose donc
nous on est peut-être plus un petit peu
plus dans les musiques du monde d'autres
seront peut-être un peu plus dans le rap
mais l'idée c'est peut-être à nous tous
d'être diversifié et puis de pas faire
la même chose que les autres et on a
aussi des typologies de salle un peu
différentes d'autres plus assises
d'autres plus debout ou mixtes donc en
voilà ça ça tout se complète et nous
notre ligne artist c'est aussi lié à la
grandeur de notre salle on est à la fois
dans des découvertes parfois très très
avertis qui sont plus des découvertes et
d'autres fois des choses un peu plus de
niche moins connus mais tout autant de
très bonne qualité et du 31 mai au 10
juin vous organisez le festival
ultra-zix c'est la cinquième édition
cette année quels sont vos ambitions à
travers ce festival alors nos ambitions
c'est de faire découvrir la culture des
Outre-mer
au plus grand nombre alors c'est
pourquoi vous allez me demander
certainement c'est parce que on s'est
rendu compte sur notre territoire
notamment on a beaucoup d'associations
qu'elles soient réunionnaise ou
antillaise ou
ou polynésienne par exemple à HR il y a
une association polynésienne
qu'elle nous demandait beaucoup de
faire un spectacle de fin d'année mais
très peu de
d'action un peu professionnelle en fait
lol les finalement des concerts dans des
lieux de musique actuelle antillais par
exemple on n'en voit pas tant que ça et
du coup on s'est dit devant toute cette
effervescence autour de nous et puis on
avait aussi un artiste réunionnais qui
s'appelle Jean-Didier Hoarau qu'on peut
retrouver dans transcabar notamment qui
est aussi le neveu de Daniel Waro qui
habite juste derrière le sac alors tout
ça réunit on a aussi un orchestre qui
est donc du coup sur les Caraïbes on
s'est dit bah tiens pourquoi pas en
faire un moment fort et du coup de
travailler sur de la diffusion
professionnelle avec des artistes en
concert et puis sur de l'action
culturelle qui
vont vers les enfants qui vont vers
les parents les familles à travers avec
l'aide de nos associations
pendant ce festival vous organisez des
cancers chez l'habitant et des concerts
à l'école quel est le principe de ces
deux modes de concert finalement alors
le concert à l'époque à l'époque à
l'école pardon
c'est simple on va avec un groupe dans
dans
l'école et on fait un concert donc ça
s'organise
gentiment c'est à dire que on est
d'accord avec l'école et puis on diffuse
le concert dans l'école c'est nous qui
allons jusqu'à eux et puis
pour les concerts chez l'habitant c'est
l'idée de partager un moment convivial
de rencontrer un artiste l'idée c'est de
créer un apéro un apéro dinatoire par
exemple l'artiste vient jouer chez vous
gratuitement et ça crée un événement on
a aussi plusieurs ateliers qui seront
proposés par exemple le 31 mai le 1er
juin deux ateliers seront proposés sur
la danse Sega maloya et l'autre sur la
danse polynésienne quelles sont les
particularités de ces deux danses et ben
elles sont différentes alors c'est un
petit peu compliqué d'expliquer mais la
Polynésie et
[Musique]
comment
les géographiquement c'est complètement
différent donc c'est pas les mêmes
cultures les mêmes
les mêmes
régions
c'est difficile de l'autre côté de la
Polynésie ce sont des danses
traditionnelles qui sont aussi liées à
la musique et surtout ce que je peux
dire sur les ateliers c'est qu'ils sont
familiales qui sont gratuits du coup
surtout l'idée d'une découverte d'une
rencontre aussi avec une danse et son
territoire car on aura aussi des
ateliers donc sur des ateliers
percussions le 3 juin d'atelier
culinaire notamment le 10 juin pour
faire dans leur le 10 juin c'est de la
wound allews et un atelier styledrun et
pour ce qui est donc atelier culinaire
c'est pareil tout au long tout au long
du festival le festival ultra zik c'est
aussi et surtout des concerts le 2 juin
pas moins de 5 artistes seront présents
que nous réserve un petit peu cette
soirée alors
c'était c'est d'ailleurs l'idée c'est
toujours l'idée de faire un concert zouk
et pour ça
on a réuni 5 femmes peut-être qu'on peut
citer
féminines qui chantent le zouk avec un
groupe du coup il y aura les musiciens
plus celles et c'est l'idée de ben voilà
de mettre en avant du champ féminin et
puis la musique zouk on va écouter
justement un court extrait de ta
priorité de Saïna ma note et on poursuit
juste après
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis perdu loin de toi
[Musique]
on se savait déjà
et le 3 juin une soirée concert avec
trois artistes et groupes cette fois-ci
qu'est-ce qui attend le public pour
cette soirée alors c'est un petit peu à
l'instar de la veille c'est un peu
l'ambiance
on sera
donc on est plus du coup dans l'océan
Indien à la Réunion et l'idée c'est de
d'appréhender cette musique le Sega
maloya et de danser bien sûr avec mini
navararo qui qui animera qui sera là en
tant que danseuse pour pour danser et
animé le 9 juin mocalami et Yann solo au
sax à HR qu'elle est pareil l'univers
musical de ces de ces artistes alors mon
Calamity c'est
une chanteuse cap-verdienne elle fait du
reggae elle est elle est connue dans le
monde du reggae c'est une ouverture vers
le Cap Vert et surtout enfin surtout
pour Tiken Jah Fakoly donc un artiste
reggae très connu la considère comme la
meilleure
chanteuse de reggae
en plein dans le reggae puis il y a une
solo c'est un artiste qu'on connaît sous
le nom de Yann cléric fait beaucoup de
projets avec d'autres artistes notamment
dans dans l'univers du jazz et là il
propose son projet il Aiguillonnais un
groove guyanais c'est à dire
il utilise les machines le hip-hop le
chant créole pour créer son son univers
ça sera à découvrir ou à redécouvrir en
tout cas le 9 juin au sac ça HR et en
fin le 10 juin Maya kamati et Christelle
seront seront sur scène on va découvrir
un court extrait et on en parle juste
après
[Musique]
quand elle quand tu veux quand elle
champagne hiver quand elle talon
poubelle
essaye encore
en concert le 10 juin il y aura
également Christelle je l'ai dit
pourquoi avoir programmé ces deux
artistes alors c'est là le le bah déjà
parce qu'elles étaient en tournée
parce que il faut les faire venir de la
Réunion donc du coup elle est en tournée
c'était le bon moment ça fait longtemps
qu'on que je cours après là on est sur
un extrait plutôt d'un ancien album
maintenant les peu guerrière et elle est
partie sur quelque chose d'un peu plus
urbain un peu plus punchy
voilà et puis Christelle c'est une
artiste de ça fasse un groupe mais au
nom de Christelle avec la chanteuse qui
s'appelle Christelle
qui vient de Madagascar du coup qui a
aussi
cet aspect un peu plus rock
urbain en fait et donc c'était une
soirée qui se met les biens en plus elle
se connaissent et du coup ça peut créer
et donc ça sera à découvrir le 10 juin
donc je rappelle le festival ultrasi que
du 31 au 10 juin prochain au Saxe à HR
merci beaucoup Frédéric Lamande et
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation pour
plus d'informations on peut se rendre
sur le site le saxr 78.fr et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]